to understand and protect the biggest
creatures on earth you have to study
this tiny thing no not my thumb
the tiny crustacean known as krill
balancing on top of it
whales consume krill and consume fish in
humongous and mouths off the coast of
San Francisco krill swarm in incredible
numbers and that attracts legions of
whales and scientists aboard the NOAA
research vessel full mark yesterday we
had at least 68 whales it all starts
with a process called upwelling winds
push warm surface waters away which are
replaced by water from the deaths that
deep cold moisture rich water and
conscious production when it comes up
near the surface worth where the Sun is
and we have the phytoplankton blooming
phytoplankton are food for krill and
lots of krill means lots of blue and
humpback whales to get a better sense of
how this ecosystem works scientists drop
sensors and drag Nets at different
depths to capture samples everything
from the net gets filtered down into
this we will take the Cod end off and
put that into our sample jar for over a
decade they've been gathering heaps of
this data and observing whales to better
understand and safeguard them one of the
greatest threats the ocean of marine
wildlife face right now is climate
change and there's early all that we can
do directly other than decreasing human
threats threats like the ships running
in and out of San Francisco Bay so
officials have used the full Mars
observation data to tweak shipping lanes
to best protect the many whales here and
now we see whales pretty often where all
these cruises sometimes we have to stop
our dry sex allow them to move in front
of us and finish feeding before we can't
continue and it just it just doesn't get
old